so letzten sonntag war tag der deutschen
einheit und dazu gibt es leider nicht
nur gute nachrichten zb wenn man sich
anguckt wo die afd bei der
bundestagswahl so ihre direktmandate
gewonnen hat 10 alleine in sachsen da
sind die stärkste kraft geworden auch in
thüringen sieht es nicht viel besser aus
was jetzt
ja das ist keine lösung jemanden die
debatte führen wir ja weiß gott nicht
zum ersten mal man kann es machen wie
sachsens ministerpräsident kretschmann
und weiter gesprächsangebote machen
wenigstens einen teil der afg klientel
oder man versucht es mit
konfrontationstherapie wie der
ostbeauftragte der groko ein gewisses
fremdeln mit
der demokratie und ihren institutionen
ist in den neuen ländern wesentlich
ausgeprägter als in den alten ländern
und zwar durchaus in einem maße dass ich
es persönlich für demokratie gefährdend
halte ja ich würde meinen da stimmte
vieles um nicht zu sagen alles worauf
ihm allerdings von einigen mit 610
sinngemäß entgegnet wurde
marco wanderwitz gerade von der sachsen
cdu abgewählt als landesgruppenchef man
gibt wohl nicht zuletzt in die schuld
für das miese ergebnis der cdu im
freistaat tatsache ist da existieren
seit jahren geschlossene rechte babbels
die gar keiner mehr erreicht zb im
erzgebirge ja das ist einfach so wenn
klar über 70 prozent der sachsen haben
eben nicht als die gewählt und man
müsste natürlich viel mehr über projekte
reden die sich in den neuen ländern für
zivilgesellschaft jugendarbeit und
demokratie engagieren
projekte übrigens die alle paar jahre um
ihre finanzierung bangen müssen weil die
unionsfraktion im bundestag das
sogenannte wehrhafte demokratie gesetzt
nicht haben wollte schade meine gut
bundesweit hat die fdp bei der wahl
natürlich verloren und seitdem ist nur
noch streit in der parteiführung vor
allem jörg merten und alice weidl können
sich gar nicht mehr aufs feld gucken
die sich den faschisten wirken als
nächsten parteivorsitzenden vorstellen
eines tages gefragt worden
alice es geht um faschismus ist eine
frage an dich
ja sie hassen sich und sie hassen sich
auch wahlleuten der alice das
wahlergebnis der afg zu schlecht redet
sie sagt die afg ist zwar auf dem papier
von 12,6 bei der letzten bundestagswahl
auf 10,3 diesmal runter gerauscht aber
es gab ja auch sondereffekte durch die
populistische konkurrenz unter anderem
durch die querdenker partei die basis
und wenn man diese sondereffekte
bereinigte dann
liegen wir sogar über dem ergebnis von
2017 an wir konnten uns deutlich
verbessern
alles weise kann wirklich sehr gut
rechnen nur halt nicht mit diesen
arabischen zahlen ja sondereffekte genau
wie bei der heute show ja bereinigt also
wenn ich einfach alle anderen sendungen
die gerade parallel laufen mit zähne
haben wir 100 prozent einschaltquote
ja in einem punkt liegt das rechengenie
hier allerdings richtig die impfgegner
von der basis partei haben für das erste
mal schon erschreckend gut abgeschnitten
1,4 prozent zweitstimmen haben die
geholt mit spots wie dem hier aus der
basis der gesellschaft erhoben männer
und frauen ihre stimmen informierten und
organisierten sich wandten widersprachen
und wehrten sich und schüttelt ganz oft
den kopf
das programm der basis kann man übrigens
in wirklichkeit auf einen punkt runter
dampfen alle corona maßnahmen beenden
der rest ist für text auch bei denen
gibt es einen radikalen flügel der zb
impfen als organisierte massentötung
bezeichnet wer glaubt sowas zu viele
menschen eindeutig in sachsen liegt die
impfquote bei gerade mal 55 prozent laut
einer aktuellen umfrage bleiben 67
prozent der hardcore impfgegner aus
trotz geimpft ja trotz die sagen ich
mache das nicht weil alle sagen dass ich
das machen soll genau deswegen schalten
wir jetzt beim mdr diesen spot
umgekehrte psychologie
liebe sachsen riesenschweinerei das
mörtel regime verbietet uns ab sofort
die impfung kein scheiß impfungen gibt
es im freistaat nur noch für ausländer
vielen dank außerdem all es die
ehrennadel folgende einschränkungen
unserer grundrechte kein sachse darf
mehr lassen radfahren vegetarisch essen
und auch sonst einen beitrag zum
klimaschutz leisten vermögen und wenn
einer von uns jemals denn dort dann
machen die da oben alle kirschen zu
moscheen hatten die eu ein impuls für
sachsen und innen zu ein wein sind jetzt
habt ihr bestimmt voll bock auf impfen
aber merkel sagt nennen doch doch doch
von der lassen wir uns doch nichts sagen
denn
sachsen wir tun das richtige erst denn
ihr schweine es uns verbietet
wenn das nicht hilft weil sie auch nicht
mehr aus dem stand 1,4 prozent für die
basis für eine partei die möglichst
viele menschen vom impfen abhalten will
und jetzt wohl über 700.000 euro
steuergeld kriegt als
wahlkampfkostenerstattung ist die
rechtslage übrigens hat die basis ganz
fest damit gerechnet die nächste
bundesregierung zu stellen es kann wird
der kanzler kandidat rainer fühl mich
hat im netz sogar schon sein kabinett
vorgestellt wie sind faktisch die neue
bundesregierung
frau fischer ist die innenministerin wir
haben uns auf die schnelle ein
kompetentes kabinett zusammen suchen
müssen aber es gibt genügend kompetente
leute ja absolut leider haben wir keine
gefunden reichskanzler für mich lautet
übrigens nicht die einzige
selbsternannte regierung ich muss ihnen
sagen es wimmelt in diesen tagen
geradezu von querdenker kabinetten wir
schreiben geschichte in dieser woche
entscheidet sich deutschlands schicksal
ich als einziger rechtmäßiger
bundeskanzler feierlich an land durch
unseren bundespräsidenten doch da
michael wendler als ihr euch zu unserer
ersten kabinettssitzung herzlich
willkommen jede minute zählt bill gates
braunlager für ungeimpfte wir sind die
letzte verteidigungslinie im kampf gegen
die diktatur und deshalb muss jeder von
euch in
moosen der außenminister ach ja der
wolfgang loest sich entschuldigen der
doppelt
kind kann man nichts machen
leute aufwachen
die impfpflicht gott wir sind der
widerstand staufenberg
2.048 freie deutsche lassen uns von
keinem irgendetwas sagen aber für gar
kein
entschuldigungsgrund deine klappe
spieler freunde aber wir sind die
bundesregierung
ich als bundeskanzler verfüge mit den
totalen sozialen medien krieg handys
raus douglas post ist jetzt bei
instagram dass man vom küssen schwanger
wird auch als man alles klar
komisch inzaghi glich wie inter geht
nicht gut an dann schreibt das
geht auch nicht die anderen abgestellten
mit internet auch nur ganz normale
idioten
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and cut
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich